[Applaudissements]
la capote sur l'obélisque à paris en
1993 c'est l'oeuvre des militants d'act
up la prévention est tellement mal fait
en france qu'il faut agir avec des gros
symbole c'est pour ça qu'on l'a en
capoter la place le message est simple
c'est sida que celle cette hécatombe
quatre ans plus tôt en 1989 act up
débarquer en france deux ans après sa
création aux états unis
[Musique]
l'association militante de lutte contre
le sida élabore des actions très
percutante pour prendre la lumière
médiatique capable de mobiliser des
milliers de personnes
leur mode opératoire de prédilection le
die in une déclinaison du sit in avec
des militants allongé en symbole des
morts du sida des slogans courts et
percutants accompagne les dahirs mais le
but premier de bloquer des routes ou
occuper des lieux symboliques comme en
1990 devant le domicile de françois
mitterrand une vingtaine de personnes a
bloqué la circulation pendant un quart
d'heure il reproche au président de la
république de ne pas s'être rendu à la
conférence internationale des
organisations non gouvernementales de
lutte contre le sida
autre type d'action le zap ce sont des
mobilisations très courte inventive
provoque surtout
[Applaudissements]
en 1991 les militants interrompre la
messe à notre-dame de paris
je crois qu'il faut dire que l'église en
france est une entrave direct à la
prévention
l'église condamne le préservatif alors
que c'est le seul moyen de sauver des
vies à l'époque actuelle
je crois que l'église a une attitude
très discriminatoires envers les
séropositifs et les malades
en 1992 il couvre de colorant rouge
un docteur mise en cause dans l' affaire
du sang contaminé milliers sion extrême
vous le docteur habib sy sentiment de
haine du côté des militants d'act up
l'opération est spectaculaire chacune
des actions d'act up a fait l'objet
d'une intense réflexion entre militants
d'act up c'est une machine de guerre
dont comme comme une arme et il fallait
y aller c'était très structuré il y
avait tout un teint une préparation des
manifestations des actions il y avait
plusieurs réunions par semaine pour pour
définir quelles cibles comment pourquoi
cette fois ci on utilise du sang
pourquoi cette fois ci n'est pas ce
qu'on utilise des cendres qui est ce
qu'on va cibler comment va ça on va
parler aux médias
les moyens de mobilisation d'acteurs
plus on garantit une importante
couverture médiatique
act up est moins active aujourd'hui mais
ces modes opératoires subsistent au sein
d'autres mouvements lgbt plus et
écologistes
[Musique]